- Des semaines de pression
soutenue sur un système déjà
désastreux pour les hôpitauxonùe
de main-d'oeuvre a forcé
la fermeture sporadiquededededee
la province traversait
Ford se ravise.
Et présente un plan en
la pression sur les hôpitaux.
Étape 1 : continuer de lutter
contre la COVID-19.
de patients en soins de longue
durée.
Étape 3 : réduire le temps
Étape 4 : améliorer
la couverture médicale dans
les régions rurales.
davantage de personnel.
"On ne peut plus accepter
le statu quo", affirme
la ministre de la Santé,
qui promet que sa stratégie
6000 travailleurs de la santé
et de libérer 2500 lits
dans les hôpitaux.
L'opposition, elle, accuse
le gouvern
le réseau public.
Car pourrererere la pression sur
les hôpitaux, le gouvernement
Ford f
dans les cliniques privées.
- onononont jamais, aucune fois,
dit le nom : privatisation.
conservateurs de ne pas avoir
é é é clairs sur leurs intentios
pendant la dernière campagne
FRANCE GÉLINAS, porte-paroledu é
- Aussitôt que tu privatises,
public qui ne sont plus
disponibles.
- Le gouvernement rétorque
qu'il s'agit d'une solution
les Ontariens n'auront jamais
besoin d'une carcrcrcrcrédit
pour accéder à des soins
de santé.
Une promesse qui n'a pas su
rassurer le milieu de la santé.
"Nous nous opposons à toutetente
réseau de la santé", a déclaré
l'Association des infirmitatatat
pas forcément contrela privatise
toutefois des précisions
de la part du gouverneme
Privatisatinonononon, le temps
presse pour stopper l'exode
du personnel après des années
le réseau de la santé à rude
épreuve. Et si les cas de CO
baissent, la pression sur
le gouvernement, elle,
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Toron